steve il faut du cran pour abandonner
ses études et aux études se font devant
d'expérience aux bas sur quoi un
terminal d'ordinateur que j'ai relié à
un poste de télévision pour l'affichage
steve
c'est de la technologie de pointe
personne fait des trucs pareils
réf
bienvenue chez apple computer toute la
société et là c'est une start up on
devra commencer avec 90 mille dollars
vous pouvez répéter ça si vous voulez
moi la société apple en bourse ce matin
nous devons rendre ces petites choses
inoubliable l'acquis hausse est pas un
problème urgent tire toi
il est fait d'entrer en guerre contre
ibm
il a toujours fait l'impossible même
depuis un garage j'essaye de développer
apple et ils veulent me l'enlever si tu
continue dans cette voie je ne pourrai
plus de protéger
c'est une escroquerie flagrante je vais
vous poursuivre pour jacques cette volée
c'est toi qui est au pire ping le
conseil est unanime
steve ne sera plus impliqué dans cette
société
dix ans après le départ de steve shops
l'avenir d'apple computer est en péril
dans la vie on n'a pas toujours la
chance de faire beaucoup de choses bien
on m'a andres apple de nouveaux
collègues
aux rebelles
au fou aux marginaux
seuls ceux qui seront assez fou pour
penser qu'ils peuvent changer le monde
il parvient
ok de commencer par lui donner un nom à
cette boîte
apple ouais ça sonne mieux que
ordinateur à séquence deux phases